it starts out we hit a million oh my god
this is amazing
then we break the record of 6.6 and
we're like then we just go quiet
like everyone was just watching silently
as it just kept going
and the timer reset every three minutes
so if any of the 33 bidders
bid again in the final three minutes it
would reset so it gave everyone a chance
to move around the board
until they had their final price
ultimately you know
we all just sat there as it went from
one to six to 11 and we were like when
is this gonna stop and then it stopped
and i was just like i didn't even know
what to do
so that was my weekend last weekend
welcome back to the 43rd
ever iced coffee hour my name is blau
and so far the podcast has made
46 000 that
thank you so much for coming on today
this is really exciting it's crazy and
we're neighbors
yes and we're neighbors finally because
we've been texting back and forth not
texting dming
on instagram for a while remember i met
you a long time ago
at uh uh nate's concert audience oh dude
a long time ago remember that yes i do
yeah we met
once and then i think we followed each
other on instagram for a while
went back and forth for like a year
through the carrot guys as well
yes because i saw that and we all have
mutual friends so now you're in vegas
how do you find
this i love it here it's so nice i
honestly i prefer it here the only thing
i'm not used to yet is the dry weather
so i wake up and like my mouth is just
like really dry
as soon as you'll get away from having
like multiple fridges or in around the
bedroom instead of going back to the
kitchen you know like
yeah it's useful yeah yeah and that's
the other thing too the house is big
so it's twice the size of the place in
la and it's weird to have to like wake
up and be like oh the kitchen is like 50
feet that way it's strange
fridge in the bedroom solves all the
problems man no but that's the beauty of
being vegas versus la i mean
the value here for what you get is
incredible yeah how long have you lived
in las vegas far
i actually dropped out of school before
my senior year
i was 19 or 20 years old at the time i
don't remember and i moved back in with
my parents because my dj career was just
exploding on the internet this is back
in like the youtube soundcloud facebook
days
right before spotify even existed and i
lived with my parents for about six
months and i said
i can't handle this i got to get my own
place um so i dropped out junior from
washington st louis
and then i moved into queens ridge tower
condo because i was moving around i'm
traveling all the time
i didn't want the responsibility of a
home finally i got so lucky i was
i wanted a backyard and before cove it
hit january of last year
screw it i want a place for the backyard
bought the house
and then covet hit and i'm so thankful
that i have a backyard
um now versus being stuck in a condo
tower during this quarantine so
uh great blessing in disguise and now
we're neighbors yeah you've had a very
successful career in music
and one of the reasons why we want to
bring you on as soon as possible
you just sold 11 million dollars in
one night of your album nft
yes eleven point seven and i like to say
that it's not one night it was really
four years of work to get to fair enough
sure sure okay but good point to
everyone who's seeing it online they're
like
48 hours eleven point seven million
dollars how did this even happen
yeah and how did this happen tell tell
the story
remember to simplify it for jack so jack
could follow along with this
easy easy easy simple so the easy story
the story is fun we won't go technical
at all
we'll do some gary vee references
because i explained some of this stuff
very well
okay it all started the beginning of the
story is my favorite
it started in mexico where i met the
winklevoss twins who
of course ever the winklevoss twins of
facebook how do you start a story of
just like
mexico winklevoss twins i feel like
there's a story within the story
so the winklevoss twins famously
discovered bitcoin in ibiza which is
already crazy and funny enough that was
long before i met them and then i met
them in 2014
i was playing a spring break music
festival opening up for avicii at the
time
rest in pisa vichy and the winklevoss
twins and i just bonded because i have a
background in finance and college i
studied uh
index derivatives and economics right
you don't have to get into that but
i met them in mexico they invited me to
stay at their place in la during grammy
week just because they love dance music
they had a studio in their house they're
like come use our studio we love your
music
i was like sure i'll come hang out with
you guys at the time they were building
their crypto exchange called gemini
and i was first discovering what bitcoin
was in 2014 and i was fascinated
by this idea of permissionless and
frictionless value transfer to simplify
that
you don't have to wait you can send
money on the weekend without waiting for
the bank yep what venmo does but
with crypto right that was just so
fascinating to me because banks are
pretty inefficient
sending money across the world is kind
of hard other
families like especially like families
that move to the united states that
immigrate that want to send money home
it's very difficult
to do that and so this idea that you can
do it via the internet this magical
internet money could exist
blew my mind in 2014 and that's when i
made my first bitcoin investment
fast forward to 2017. we saw
what you guys probably all know as the
ico boom the altcoin boom whatever you
want to call it
and a lot of people made a lot of money
on speculative ideas
that really had barely any merit in the
sense that they were just ideas
kind of like what we saw in the dot com
era with everything was just a website
no matter whether you needed a website
for it or not
everything was going to have a website
right so
i was already kind of involved on a
simple investment level from 2014 but in
17
i saw a lot of projects that made grand
promises and had no execution
so i had this very grand idea called our
music festival the idea is really simple
you pull a bunch of people's money the
people who pull the money get to pick
the lineup for the festival
and then they get to share in the
profits of all the tickets sold
that but with a cryptocurrency right
that was the concept of course we
learned after i hired great lawyers that
that would be a security token and it
would be illegal to do an ico in that
way so we never did an ico
i just raised equity for this company
and we threw a giant festival with zed
big sean myself with uh simple wallet
crypto rewards at the festival with qr
codes it was like kind of a playful game
and it worked out great but at the time
in 2017-2018
the regulatory environment was uncertain
the the laws surrounding this stuff
were hard to really comply by and i just
wanted to do the right thing so we shut
down the company
and moved on but through that process i
made so many relationships
with incredible people in the crypto
space one of whom michael saylor
um who yeah wish you would have been on
that call but we'll get you on with him
again
oh i remember yeah sorry i was able to
make that yeah yeah he is brilliant when
it comes to
you know how he thinks about bitcoin but
i've also had the pleasure of meeting
fred aires i'm one of the founders of
coinbase who's a who's a friend
of mine who's been kind of coaching me
through
what's happening right now are you in
the ipo um no i'm not oh
i'm not um i want to get in if somebody
could get me in on that
listen gosh i want to be so that's gonna
be a big one
um okay i could always ask him but i i
don't i i wouldn't even want to ask him
that question that's a little bit
fair but no but but but fred now
actually um started his own fund when he
left coinbase called paradigm
and famously turned 300 million into
what is now probably worth 4 billion
since march
of last year he took a big bet when
crypto crashed right when covet hit
he was like this is the chance he took
the funds money
poured it into bitcoin and just won big
and there's a forbes article about it
and
fred's in my opinion one of the smartest
people in the entire blockchain space
and so
he's been a trusted friend and advisor
so i'm talking to him tomorrow about
how to you know proceed with this nft
thing in the right way so now let's get
to the
why we're all here today um 11.7 million
dollars
for the tokenized version of my debut
album which is called ultraviolet and
the concept behind that was creating a
collectible edition of something that's
digital
what people really are confused about
when they think about what an nft is
they say well i can copy this file
as many times as i want so why do i pay
for an nft right it's free
and the the equation is very simple the
best analogy i like to give
is the hoeness wagner baseball card or
even a pokemon card great example
i could easily recreate a holographic
charizard would cost me like 100 bucks i
find a company to print it make a fake
one
so why is it that the real one is worth
250 350 000
when the fake one is costs about 100 100
bucks to make
because there's emotional sentimental
value in owning something that's
authentic
so now when you apply that to the
blockchain to keep it as simple as
possible
you have an official edition of a media
file versus an unofficial edition of a
media file
and if you give people the ability to
show off their collection
basically show off that they supported
this artist
or supported this piece of content they
are excited by the emotion of owning
that content now they might not own the
ip rights or anything like that
they're just excited to say i supported
this person in their digital creative
endeavor the same way we see people
tipping on twitch
the same way we see that happening
across the internet in a lot of other
ways
and so for all of you listening who
don't know what an nft is
the simple version is the the acronym is
non-fungible token
um but what it really means is it's just
a digital certificate
of authenticity like a land eat but on
the blockchain
so that really applies once you kind of
understand what a digital certificate of
authenticity means
it literally applies to everything not
just art
art is kind of the first step so what
did you sell exactly
what did people bid i think the topic
was 2.3
3.6 3.6 million dollars six six six you
know
yeah yeah do you do you know the person
who bid that top end
funny enough i did not um the top bidder
has kept his identity anonymous which is
very you know still here
still um well i mean i have his email
address but beyond that but he would
he wouldn't think to like be like yo let
me get on the phone with you you're a
pretty big fan right like
a lot of people who participate in this
stuff
really prefer an anonymity because you
know the amount of money that they made
in crypto
and they like to they prefer to remain
anonymous a lot of them have pseudonyms
um and whale shark who got the number
two position who ended up spending 2.5
again um has a very big public presence
but
no one knows who he actually is
underneath his pseudonym well shark so
he's got a discord
group so curious 4 000 collectors we can
dive into like who these people are and
what they're doing but
because i don't know who uh bitter 65 is
or 64.
i forget um whale shark though and i had
a relationship prior and we talk a lot
about
collectibles and art and um i was very
surprised by his
just excitement about this and now you
know
he was the one featured in the forbes
article because i you know i was able to
introduce him
right at least on email to forbes and
yeah and yeah so
what do they get what do they get yes
explain
but first we have a quick word from our
sponsor ladder life is full of reminders
of its beauty whether i'm chilling by
the pool
swimming some laps or just having a good
time making videos about life insurance
experiences like these are great
reminders of how beautiful life is and
exactly why it should be protected
on that note it makes sense why people
get life insurance especially long-term
coverage which is surprisingly
affordable why not pay a little bit each
month to protect the ones that you love
if you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it
impressively fast and easy to get
covered all you need is a few minutes
a phone or a laptop to apply ladder's
smart algorithms work in real time so
you'll find out instantly if you're
approved there are no hidden fees and
you can cancel at any time and since
life insurance costs more as you age
now is the time to cross it off your
list so lock in your best rate today and
get your family covered with ladder
go to ladderlife.com iced coffee that's
ladder l-a-d-d-e-r
life dot com slash iced coffee
ladderlife.com
iced coffee thank you so much ladder for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
imagine there's an official edition of a
song now you can go listen to a song on
spotify
but that's not an asset you're just
listening to that within spotify
imagine you have like think about the
old days with with real records if you
went to the record store
and they had no more nirvana vinyls you
couldn't even listen to nirvana
so these records would trade in the
aftermarket for crazy amounts of money
now today you can obviously still listen
to any song
on my album by going to spotify but it's
impossible to verifiably own it
own an official signed copy on the
blockchain of that song
so what people bought were audio-visual
pieces of art
that i created digital art with the
music in the background
but they also bought a vinyl nft which
is redeemable for a real world vinyl so
they bought
this you know digital asset that they
can use to
you know as a basically coupon to get
one of the 33 vinyls from my album and
they're the only 33 vinyls we will ever
print
now vinyls historically have had crazy
resale value
right and so a lot of this is the idea
that i've only made 33
vinyls of my album my album has
accumulated over 100 million streams
and so some people probably bought the
collection for the vinyl
some probably bought it for the
collection of song nfts these official
editions
of the song but i kind of surprised
people in the middle of the auction and
said
the top six people get all access passes
to any show ever
that i play in the future what's the
value of being backstage at edc
right not many people get that kind of
access and so my feeling is that people
just wanted to participate in this
auction to show
that the music business is about to
change in a huge way these people all
who've been on this who ended up in the
top 33 which
i had no idea was going to go this way
what did you think what do you think it
was going to sell for i would have been
happy at 500 000
because my last job we did was 250 000
yeah
the auction mechanic and this is like we
don't have to dive too deep into nash
equilibrium game theory economics i'm a
math guy we don't have to go there but
um i designed this auction mechanic
specifically for this reason but i
didn't expect it to succeed the way it
did
but the reality is all these people you
know they didn't just buy the digital
collectibles
they bought a statement they bought a
statement to the music industry that
artists have power to monetize
themselves without a record label
people believe in that vision so they
yes they don't get to own the like the
rights to this song
that's next that's next like we can talk
about
imagine a world so this is step one
owning a piece of unique digital content
that can't be
you can't replicate it because it's code
on the blockchain it will only ever
exist
as that can't be duplicated that's what
an nft means it's just a code
that represents ownership in something
where this goes in the future imagine
you can invest in your favorite song
and then collect a royalty on that song
imagine you can invest in
an artist that you like like in in my
case the chainsmokers and millennium
both opened for me back in the day in my
career i believed in millennium so hard
when we started you know just when we
met and millennium is
there is very excited about doing his
first nft launch which i don't want to
reveal too much but elenium if i could
have invested in millennium's music back
when i believed in him
the royalties that i'd get from that
today would be immensely valuable right
i would own a piece of the ip now the
reason why that can't happen today is
because of the regulatory environment
which is too technical we don't have to
go there
but that's the next step of this
actually owning rights in the music as a
fan
then you don't need a record label
anymore because you could fundraise from
fans
how'd you come up with the idea to do
this this is something i've been
thinking about for six years
this isn't this is uh before nfts were
even a thing yeah
i've been an independent artist my whole
career i've never given up i've given up
rights on some of my songs yeah
like i did a song with ninja and you
know ninja
put this together with astroworks which
is underneath the major record label
right so i couldn't really
tokenize that song without their
permission but my last album i owned all
the master rights
so i have the ability to do whatever i
want with it and i had that vision for
my whole career and i was
always in the public like encouraging
people to own their master rights own
their master rights
because then you can control your own
music a lot of artists that are going to
want them
into music nfts now aren't going to be
able to with their old music
because they're in a record deal and the
record label is going to want to take
what they typically take is 80 percent
imagine if
like 11.7 million that i did when 80
went to a record label
oh my god do you have to split that nft
cost with like uh
cause i know like some of the nft
companies out there will take like 50
percent
did you did you create your own or i
could so that's also why i created this
on my own website with a company that i
invested a crypto company that i
invested in
so that i wouldn't have to pay a crazy
fee wow
so that's how it worked um but i've been
involved in this
world for years and having it
come to fruition the way that it did at
this moment in time in the universe when
everyone's been quarantined and people
are moving to the digital world
in such a such an extreme way it was it
was a moment
and and logan kind of had a similar
moment and you know grimes
did 5.5 million in nft sales and you
know and people
you know had a people sold for those of
you who aren't familiar with people
let's talk about people for a second
because
he is also a pioneer here people was a
digital artist who made
had a huge instagram account for a
really long time like
just lots of followers never really got
paid fairly for this work that he did
that he spends hours and hours and hours
on
and he sold a piece for the election it
was this brilliant concept it was a
digital
programmable digital art where if trump
won it would turn one way
if biden won it would turn another way
so when biden won
the nft became it changed states
right it became the biden video clip the
biden victory video clip after the
election
and that piece sold for 66 000
originally
it sold for 6.6 million dollars three
days ago
do you worry that we're in a bit of a
bubble
yes i know okay i think that it's the
same with the real art world so when
people
i'm sure you all have seen or maybe you
know the japanese billionaire who bought
a hundred million dollar basquiat
painting
was that the one on his amex i'm not
sure okay it's possible yeah
a japanese thing so it's possible pretty
sure you bought it on the amex to get
the points
i i've listened uh if i believe it or
not believe it or not
you're going to find the article put it
up here that's a genius i'm pretty sure
he got the points
you're probably right but what is the
value of a basquiat painting
it's the what did it cost him to make it
was the canvas
cost 100 bucks the paint what are you
buying when you buy
you're buying a feeling you're buying an
emotional connection
to a piece of art that someone else made
there's no other reason
why you would pay a hundred million
dollars for something that you could
replicate if you go on amazon right now
this is my favorite example
you can go on amazon and buy the mona
lisa you know how much it costs
53 bucks it's exactly the same as the
original monolith the same size
to the t it's exactly the same
but why would you want to own a fake
mona lisa but wouldn't you
argue that those pieces of art have had
probably a hundred years
to appreciate i don't think those pieces
just went from being worth let's say 60
grand to
6 million and a year right i think that
that appreciation is
pretty nuts but i also think that people
believe in beeple as being like
the first pioneer of this entire
movement
and that's why after that sold for 6.6
million he actually he actually has an
auction
going on with christie's right now that
i think don't quote me on it i think
it's up to 2.8
already for another piece so clearly
there are multiple people that are
interested in owning
this historical work and people are
interested in owning my music in a
collectible way
um you can't deny the market it's there
how much speculation is there
i don't know but i know that i own a
people to give you an example i own a
people
that i that was 969 dollars that i could
sell today for 170
thousand dollars but i'm not selling it
so can i see it
can you pull it yeah i am so curious to
see like what this looks like
absolutely it's a it's a piece called
into the ether
is there any way you could screen record
this or just like or just do a
screenshot that way we could just
put it up absolutely um
hold on i'm so curious this is exciting
okay
so so there's another problem with the
crypto universe which is that
there really isn't a good way to mobily
display all this stuff yet and we're
everyone in crypto is building these
tools right now
yeah i would love to see like a digital
museum like
there's an apple on this you click on it
you could look through scroll through
the museum maybe you put on like a vr
headset
and you could walk around the museum
yeah i'm logged alright and this is
going to take me a second
here because i want to show you the
official version i'm not going to show
you just a picture of it right
all right let's see just logging in here
give me a moment but there are virtual
museums
and they are sick all right if you don't
have a vr headset graeme i'm buying
inoculus too
it seems like everyone that i've talked
to about nft so far are all
selling nfts like i haven't talked to a
single person that's buying nft
so i'm saying i have 50 pieces
that i own and i also sell my stuff i
love it
in my like if you ever come to my house
you'll see i have digital screens all
over the house that i
sh i display my art on and it's just
like
imagine that you came into my house and
you looked at this tv screen that looks
like a piece of art
and you're like what's that and i'm like
oh it's just like an image i found on
the internet or i'm like oh it's this
artist that i bought that and they're
like
how did you buy that i'm like no i
supported the artist i bought this piece
of digital art
and when you come over to my house i
know you have that experience where you
kind of get it
when you're looking around at all the
screens and you're like wait justin owns
this stuff
i think nfts are valid like i totally
think it's it's a it's a reasonable like
legit thing
but at the same time it seems like the
demand is coming out of the woodworks
it's like and maybe that's just because
the whole anonymity thing like
with crypto or anything but it i would
be the type to have a screen though or
just change the picture every day be
like yeah i can change but you can
but that's what what you can do right
like you can all the pieces that you own
right you can display on one screen they
don't have to be on separate screens no
i'm just saying i just find a random
picture on google and be like yeah i own
that it'll be like what you in the
picture no the tv
at some point at some point someone's
gonna figure out whether or not it's
legit unfortunately i can't log into my
account right now so
oh is it slow wi-fi what i can do is i
can i can screen record this fair enough
yes cool and then you'll see like the
edition number and then you'll see how
much it's going for in the aftermarket
and you'll see the price that i paid
is there a price that you would sell
that for
how much to be honest i probably won't
because it means something to me um i
mean
i maybe if you spoke to me before this
latest sale maybe i'd feel differently
just because of the change in my
life um but even then
i probably wouldn't there's some pieces
that i would
not every piece do i feel like is a
piece for life but like owning one of
the first people pieces
in in years from now i mean these things
appreciate incredibly
in value art does real art does and this
is the first form of digital art from
one of the most well-known digital
artists so
i would love to pass it down to my kids
to be dead you know i
like the way people have passed down
picassos right
i really believe that and i know it's
kind of crazy but what i would suggest
to you guys is you can buy digital art
for way cheaper than some of the prizes
you're seeing
find an artist that you think is
interesting and just try it pay the 300
see if it makes you feel something and i
guarantee you it will
what are you gonna do with all the money
but really quick we have a word from our
sponsor fundrise
in 2021 a truly diversified portfolio
needs
more than just the traditional mix of
stocks bonds and mutual funds
it needs private real estate studies
have shown that portfolios with an
allocation to private real estate have
generally delivered a better risk
adjusted return
with more annual income and lower
volatility over the past two decades
with fundrise this level of powerful
diversification is now available to you
fundrise provides access to diversified
portfolios of private
real estate to all investors with their
industry-leading easy to use platform
whether you're looking to add stable
cash flow via dividends or prefer
long-term growth through appreciation
fundrise makes investing in private real
estate as easy as investing in stocks
bonds or mutual funds see for yourself
how 130
000 investors have built a better
portfolio with private real estate it
takes just a few minutes to get started
go to fundrise.com
iced coffee today that's fundrise
f-u-n-d-r-i-s-e risc.com
iced coffee fundrise.com iced coffee
thank you so much fundraise and back to
the podcast
i'm curious where so what's your plan
i'm going to start a foundation this
this is
you know however this take it as you
will like this is obviously
a great amount of money but i've also
been a bitcoin investor for a very long
time and i've
my mission is to support other artists
so even before my
you know auction we did a clubhouse room
where i was like i'm going to spend 33
000 on your digital art if you're a new
artist come up to the stage and pitch it
to me
and i didn't end up buying every
everyone's pitch i bought like maybe
five things that i really liked um so
i'm definitely gonna take a big portion
of this money and support the new
nft art community um i've you know my
record label
that i built we donated over you know
330 thousand dollars to building schools
in guatemala
um with an organization called pencils
of promise i'm always about giving back
and this
obviously we're going to be giving back
in a big way with this kind of money
because it's
crazy i mean the community came out to
support me in my vision but
what i do want to really stress is this
feels like it's a little bit speculative
i would encourage you to just
buy something for 50 to give you an
example
i bought my friend slime sunday i bought
one of his pieces
called the last stand of the nation
state for forty dollars
and i as a joke i put it up for sale at
eight thousand dollars
there were only four hundred editions
ever minted my price got hit and i
panicked because i actually i
did it as a joke i'm just gonna put this
up for resale for eight grand
that's insane and now it's nine and it's
19 today where do you buy it
where do you buy an nft how can we do
this you nifty gateway
you can go there you can go to open c
foundation
super rare those are all the main
platforms nifty gateway enables credit
cards so you don't have to know anything
about crypto
to start collecting but i want to say
this don't buy to make money like a lot
of people are
themselves this is going to be a profit
operator no buy stuff that you like
the same way you buy real art i mean i i
buy realtor i have a lot of real art in
my house
i buy it because i love those artists
and i don't like plan on flipping it
so i would say like if you if something
is digitally interesting to you
just explore like 40 bucks i'm not a
skeptic at
all of like nfts and i think it's a it's
a move in the right direction to move it
to move it like online i think that's
great because like it's kind of weird
but like
we live in a finite world but we have
like
infinite desires and aspirations right
so to move
everything onto a digital platform where
we can expand
infinitely i think is a great idea and
also i love the idea that it's
it can be one of one and and not you
know like it's it's the true
valid like so now imagine something else
right i want to
take this to the next level beyond the
investment part which i'm you know maybe
that resonates with you like owning the
royalties of a song you know some of my
music has generated significant
royalties my song is at love
has generated over you know 330 000 in
royalties just for that one song
what if you what if i told you graham
like back when i made it if you liked it
you could own five percent of that
but you could own it for like 500 bucks
like that would be totally a
great investment right and so thinking
about in that way that's the future but
there's another way to think about it
too
what if owning an nft gives you access
to both exclusive digital content
but also gives you access to things in
real life for instance
imagine an nft unlocks all my unreleased
songs on my website
which is what we're doing by the way
with this you can listen to all the
ideas that i'm working on
in real time when they're not finished
and only these 33 people will have that
ability
but they have to have the ethereum token
in their wallet they have to sign a
message to ethereum to prove
now could they rip it yeah but look how
much money they paid you think they want
to show that to everyone they might show
it to their friends when they're over
but they're not sharing that
yeah and if someone else tried to get on
the website they physically couldn't
because they didn't have the token in
their wallet
take this a step further let's say
you're at one of my shows and you own an
all-access nft
i have like i'm gonna let you backstage
because you can prove to me that you own
it
by signing a message on your phone that
shows that your wallet
owns the all-access nfc and i could take
you backstage we only made six of them
ever
so let's say you want to go backstage
you go you experience it now you can
resell it
and every time you resell it i get 10
how incredible is that so these things
have real real world functionality
not just digital functionality gosh you
know we should do that with a mentorship
group man
honestly it's just a great idea to
create a hundred nf2
100 nfts that we could just basically do
like like a once a month sort of like
mastermind that's smart we should i like
that
how do we do that man we'll we'll talk
about that there's a long conversation
but like
rac is another artist yeah who has
tokens that
unlock access to a discord server that
is a direct channel of communication to
him but you have to own it
let's do that that's exactly what and we
want to do that all right that's our
idea
this makes a little a little bit more
sense as you make sense
for that i'd say it makes sense in the
sense
it's just it's security i like that
it's resellable i like that and
uh i guess that's what i like about it
let's talk about you first sure okay
that's a great example
all right how many of the people
watching would love to have a
community around you only 100 people get
direct access to you
maybe you don't talk on this discord
server every single hour of every day
but every night before you go to sleep
you go through the hundred people that
might have questions for you what's the
value of that pass
for your fans what do you think that
might be like well like for
per person how do you how do you say
this is for life like how do i know i'm
going to be like 80 years old and like
discord's still going to be
like it's your commitment you have to
make to them yeah
you have to you can create a you know
terms and conditions just like anything
else in the world
you can say listen this gives you access
to this discord group i can guarantee
you i'm going to be popping in at least
once every week
but now you build a community around you
of people that can talk to each other
that are your biggest fans
so whether you pop in every week or not
they can talk i don't want to throw out
a number because then i'm then i'm
setting myself
up for that number okay it's uh we
should do that
honestly don't throw out a number but
let me tell you something our first nft
yeah some of them sold for 200 bucks
they're selling for
five to ten thousand dollars now why
just because honestly people believe in
my vision for the future of music
which i've expressed on clubhouse i've
talked on a lot of podcasts like uh
apomp pompolino you know i've talked on
um a bunch of people's podcasts just
describing what i think the music
business will become and people believe
in that vision they want to support that
vision and that's why they're buying
this stuff
and i'm hopefully going to shape that i
mean that's kind of what happened
this this this past weekend which is
honestly like the craziest moment of my
life
um i don't know if you saw but in my
high school yearbook it says
like lifestyle to revolutionize the
music business and like that literally
like
i'm on cloud nine right now because i
feel like i didn't do it yet
but i took a big step and the reality is
creators
like yourself are we've been dependent
on platforms for so long
when you have a token that someone else
owns you
have direct access to those people you
don't have to go through a platform and
that's a
whole other conversation that we can
dive into um let's say you make
let's say you make 10 000 nfts for your
truest fans you can send them messages
on the blockchain without even emailing
them like and it's all decentralized and
no one can stop you from doing it
no one can ban your account no matter
what and so giving creators that kind of
power
going direct to fan is unstoppable
that's intro i want to do that i want to
do that one that that i think has uh
a lot of capabilities for everybody
there's an application for everything
all right i like that you convinced me
that's what i'm here for man that's why
we're talking about revolutionizing the
uh mentorship group now too
sure honestly like if i was if i was a
young kid who wanted to follow in your
footsteps
you're extremely successful you speak so
well to
both investments real estate there's so
many people out there that would love
your perspective
on either a one-on-one basis or a one on
100 basis
i mean if i was a younger kid and i
would save money i would pay five to ten
grand for that
but you should say like 50 or 100
beginners but yeah yeah yeah yeah
hold on maybe like you know are those
kids gonna be able to afford it i don't
know
but maybe you get maybe it starts out
there but remember like i sold some of
my first stuff for 200
you start out in a place that makes
sense but if the demand is there
you expand right people sold his first
piece for one dollar
and it's going for a hundred thousand
and he's capturing ten percent of all
the resales every time it resells
so let me ask you a question would you
rather underprice yourself and capture
ten percent of every other transaction
or overprice yourself so much that maybe
you don't attract a buyer
ten percent of five times you know
50 like if it goes for 20 and then 30
and then 50 and then
yeah all if it changes hands all those
times but it started at one
well you get 10 of every time it changes
hand why not just do the bidding system
like you did
give give like the top 50 your top 100
and the the number one person gets like
a once
once a year meet up and there's a random
like that's exactly what we did which is
like hardcore game theory economics
right that i studied in college and
that's why it worked but it's also very
risky and like we didn't know it would
play out
like there's there's a lot of math
behind it there's a lot of like special
features that the collectors know that
they have that no one else knows yet
because now i've created a community of
33 people who
changed my life and so i'm going to make
sure their investment in my art
is worth something and they're going to
get so much other that we didn't even
announce yet
so you know you can play this however
you want the beauty is
it's not like youtube or spotify where i
upload a song and then i let the
algorithm decide what happens i have
full control over the engagement with my
community
and that's the power of this so it's not
like whether you price it at a thousand
or five thousand
the beauty of it is the fans can decide
what the value is
and you'll capture all of it as it
changes hands
so to give you perspective before this
11.7
we had done about 1.1 me and my art
director combined so pretty big jump
like all the other ones were 1.1 then
this was 11.7 kind of crazy
but that 1.1 has resold in the resale
market
with 4 million of sales volume after we
sold it
at its initial prices which means that
people value this stuff did you do any
marketing
ahead of time because i saw you in
morning brew
i loved that i read uh read morning brew
pretty much every morning
saw you on there and i'm wondering like
we did marketing before the auction
because because i went out on my own i
didn't use a platform like
platforms have built-in audiences like
nifty gateway has an audience of people
that literally just buy everything
because they love this stuff
yeah i had to basically gather my
hardcore fan base and bring them to my
own website
and hope that they were going to bid and
so we did some marketing because
i was nervous that we were going to host
it i was the first
nftrs ever to host a sale on my own
website
like shopify versus you know sotheby's
right
and i was nervous but they showed up
[Music]
but i had no idea man yeah i had no clue
right once it hit
my family was with me in the house and
it starts out we hit a million oh my god
this is amazing
then we break the record of 6.6 and
we're like then we just go quiet
like everyone was just watching silently
as it just kept going
and the timer reset every three minutes
so if any of the 33 bidders
bit again in the final three minutes it
would reset so it gave everyone a chance
to move around the board
until they had their final price game
theory nash equilibrium
um you guys if you're curious about the
math behind it you can just
wikipedia game theory and nash
equilibrium um
and you'll figure out how i designed
this but ultimately
you know we all just sat there as it
went from 1 to 6 to 11 and we were like
when is this gonna stop
and then it stopped and i was just like
i didn't even know what to do
so that was my weekend last weekend did
any of it not feel real
it didn't i felt like i was the past
four days by the way this is the first
conversation i've had with someone in
real life
all i've been is on the phone with other
artists musicians people that want to
get involved not to name any names but
pretty much like everyone who you know
who you like like musically is probably
going to be doing this very soon
so and how did you get oh also us if you
think
everyone's gonna get on board with like
selling nfts kind of asked you a little
bit before we started recording
but do you think that that would create
a too big of a supply
where the prices would go down it
depends
just like youtube how many youtubers are
there a lot of youtubers
but people choose to follow you because
they believe in your message the same
thing will happen
with nfts there'll be a lot of noise
people won't be able to sell stuff
but if it's meaningful to someone else
it will sell just like any other market
just like for musicians how many
musicians are there on spotify that have
less than a thousand listeners
it's just like anything else so will
there be an overflood of supply because
people think they're gonna make money
yes but as bigger artists do this and
their fans come on board maybe fans
start to really
see the value and as more big people big
artists come
more collectors will come and eventually
it'll balance out but there is a lot of
hype right now
we can't deny that right we can't deny
that what was the music industry like
before all of this let's go back when
you were like 19.
how much were you making back then like
how did you get your music out there how
did you grow as an artist so i disclosed
this on nbc now so i'm happy to kind of
all right a little bit but but you know
outside of my investment portfolio i
like you
i i admire you because i watch some of
your videos and you are a saver and an
investor and i didn't buy any luxury
goods
until this house that i just bought like
nothing for eight years
like you know i'm i'm very like-minded
for that sense um
put most of my money that i made over
the years in multi-family real estate
assets and in bitcoin
like that's pretty much it not really
many equities i trade equity derivatives
that's a whole other conversation
um but or index derivatives but um when
i started out i was 19
and that year i made 400 grand how
playing shows all around the country at
colleges
really in front of thousands of people
how big of a following did you have back
then
just facebook following of like maybe 50
to 100 000 people are you serious how
much would you get per show
it would range anywhere between three to
ten thousand for the first eight months
and then it would go and then it went up
to
12 and then it went up to 15 and went up
to 20 and then over the years it just
keeps going up because
people pay for tickets it's simple
people buy a ticket
and if i sell this many tickets it
generates this much money and that's
that and then after everyone else is
paid you know what's left
to me yeah how did you get a following
of 50 to 100 000 on facebook
i made mashups i mixed popular songs
with popular vocal popular dance songs
and popular vocals
and one just went viral on youtube and
then i was playing colleges for well it
started even lower than that started 500
bucks
i was like a kid in college i was junior
year and i would go out on the weekend
to get to make like 1500 bucks like
i fly to like georgia tech university
and play a fraternity basement slept in
like you know
slept in one of the frat brothers like
beds in the wow like that's where it all
started in fraternities and
all around the country and sororities
and then it went up to like opening up
for wiz khalifa
at university of connecticut opening up
for macklemore at duke
how do you go from that to macklemore my
agent who i've been with
this whole time at the time like edm was
barely a thing it was like right at the
start of avicii
this is like 2006 2011
11 12 okay yeah when it really started
to hit got it and there weren't that
many american artists that were doing it
at the time so
i just had good timing i guess um but
yeah my when i was
four 19 thousand dollars left dropped
out of school my economics professor
convinced my parents to let me drop out
of school
and then it was all you know upward from
there every year doubling doubling
doubling
and then over the years not spending my
money on anything putting it into
bitcoin putting it into real estate and
just
understanding that money doesn't really
come overnight and then all of a sudden
this happens
how much do you charge per show now it
ranges
it ranges it's definitely a lot more
than it was i don't i don't want to like
give a specific number because it ranges
depending on how far i have to travel
right what the demands are but you know
it's definitely a lot more than what
let's say i wanted you to dj like like a
house party here like play music
for me but but pretend we weren't
friends and we're like hey man
uh my agent's gonna yeah
there was a time that it went from 500
bucks to 3 000 to 12 000 to 15 000. you
know like there was a time in my career
where that happened
now it's a lot more but it depends on
the circumstances you know like
um to give you an example one of my best
friends um who helped me in the crypto
space early on
keith for boy i'm sure you've heard of
him he's started a company called open
door he's one of the original paypal
mafia guys
he's his birthday is in miami uh i'm
gonna get my second shot i'm gonna go
play his
birthday party i wanna go hang out cause
i'm celebrating this event and all my
friends are down there
he ain't paying for that i wouldn't
charge him you know you and i will
become friends and you know
we'll throw a party you're my next-door
neighbor yeah
i tell people i don't get paid to dj i
get paid to put my body through health
traveling to dj yeah
that's the hard part like i get offers
sometimes you go to india
and they're really big offers but like
the 48 hours of hell to go and come back
is hard yeah so unless i have multiple
shows in india lined up
so that i can you know go hit them all
at once it's hard to get me to go there
for
you know 24 hours and i get that so it's
really just
price is a function of anything else
like you know if if someone wants me to
go who's a friend who wants me to do
something
my buddy matt como who's a big uh
instagram and you know
photographer videographer he just said
dude like all of our friends are gonna
i'm throwing a birthday party in la it's
in venice beach you wanna come
you want to play it i'm like yeah i do
all my friends are going to be there i'm
going
to
go play you don't have to shoot or
anything right like so i always tell
people that i dj because i love djing i
make music because i love making music
i get paid because i hate traveling i
hate it which is why it's been kind of
nice
it makes sense makes sense uh what was i
are you finally spending your money now
not really no uh besides the house you
splurged i just i
finally bought a car finally yeah what
did you get the new f8 spider
um but outside of that like i i don't
i prefer investing in people i like
investing in people with crazy ideas and
so like carrot
great example right like i'm investing
in carrot because i believe in eric's
vision right you know
i like investing in things that will
shape the world for the better
that's the best thing about capital is
deploying it into ideas that change the
world
and so i like to be a part of that story
and like
things are nice like i don't really own
a nice watch maybe i'll go i've never
been a watch guy but now everyone's like
oh you should get to get away
you should go buy this you know attack
you should p pay tech you go
i've never been a watch guy but like you
know it's a store of value because
what's happening with the dollar right
now right like maybe the watch is
actually a better decision than holding
this kenneth
rolex daytona that's right as well as
daytona yes that's the one you want
versus an ap i was looking at okay
yeah dude we'll talk about watching all
right i don't know anything about
watching maybe you'll give me some
recommendations
am i spending my money now no i'm
definitely excited aside from the car
like i'm mostly excited about investing
in young ideas
young artists investing you know
investing in i'm going to create a
foundation
you know i already had a non-pro
not-for-profit um now i'm going to
create an actual 501c3 foundation and
do a lot of really cool stuff to help
new artists that can't pay for
you know just can't pay to get don't
even you know have the ability to buy
the software
right like someone could be so talented
but maybe they can't afford to pay for
adobe
like i want to help those people and pay
it forward and so that's really
you know how i think about monies is i
want to
use whatever money i have to create more
value in the world for other human
beings
by believing in people and and real
estate assets that's why we're right
and real estate assets right how much
real estate do you want how do you get
into that
i would say half of my net worth is in
multifamily real estate okay
um we all know 1031 exchange
you know and how powerful that can be um
i own a lot of units in texas and
florida you know i'm not going to tell
you exactly
how many but i have a lot of units in
texas and florida across different
properties
that i've invested from day one first
400 grand
200 into multi-family real estate when i
was 19. like literally been doing this
how did you learn about that my dad is a
real estate guy i'm very thankful
you know he he guided me when i started
making any money he was like justin
this is how you do it like don't spend
it
don't be don't buy the car and i you
know
i haven't bought the car of my dreams
until today
yeah after all this time because
the compound interest is such a powerful
thing
and there's a lot of really interesting
stuff happening in the cryptocurrency
space for those of you who want to get
involved
it is easy to take the first step it's
hard to take the second step
which is really understanding how all
this stuff works but nfts make it simple
because
unlike a cryptocurrency where you look
at bitcoin and
someone's like this is like 50 000 how
am i gonna buy one of them
you can't think about it that way you
have to think about it as it's okay to
own point zero zero one of something we
just haven't been trained that way
austrian economics this idea of dollars
and cents is
is just a theory someone came up with a
long time ago that doesn't really apply
to anything today
and once you start like thinking about
it and really diving in
it all starts to make sense and you'll
you'll have and i hope you have
michael saylor would have helped you on
that call and i'll get you on the phone
next
the next one this one he he speaks so
well
to the aha moment that you have when
like pennies don't really make sense
anymore
the idea of a penny like i've been a big
proponent of getting rid of the penny
let's be real i think we should let's
abolish the penny
canada did it it works really well we
don't need the pennies
how can you trust a financial system
that has
no backing we keep printing dollars
like it's nothing so what do i do i want
to invest
in ideas in art in bitcoin in real
estate
why do i invest in real estate probably
for a similar reason to you everybody
needs a place to live
right no matter what you need a place to
go home to
and that's why real estate has been such
a powerful asset over the years but
you know for anyone who's watching who's
a young entrepreneur who follows you and
you're a great voice
for our for that young generation thanks
you really are man i gotta hand it to
you
watch your videos thank you you're
teaching people to be financially
responsible
with their success and
you know before youtube a lot of people
would just blow their money on
right and it's it's nice to splurge
sometimes but
within reason invest that's your mission
that's your that's your message
invest right right and we all know how
powerful that is
so props to you man thank you what do
you do for fun
i make music really i make music what
about besides music
oh hey i'm like if you have a friend and
i are pretty lucky like uh she's an
actress
um she's got a really awesome trilogy
uh coming out on netflix this summer
called fear street you guys should check
it out okay she's she's awesome
um and you know we tell us about her for
a second
how long have you guys been together a
long time okay it's been a long time but
she's actually
she would she would have come
unfortunately but she's she's home with
the family
she went home unfortunately and missed
we didn't know that this was gonna be
such a big deal but she missed
the auction moment unfortunately but
you'll meet her in person okay sure
but i i think that you know the the
reality is that
happiness manifests itself for people in
different ways the way i
feel like i'm happy is when i make a
positive change in the world and
hopefully what happened this past
weekend
influences other artists not to sign
that new record deal
that was always my mission in life
record labels take have taken advantage
of artists for years because artists
just
they want their shot they want to get
some money so that they don't have to go
to the
their day job and they can just be
creative but they can get that money
from fans if they even just have a
little bit of a following
there's this artist fuocious great great
nft artist highly recommend you guys
check
check them out fuoshas is 18
makes really abstract work and turn to
crypto art
just because they're one of the earliest
adopters of this stuff
18 years old on average does between a
million and three million dollars every
drop
they make abstract art they came from
a family here they actually from las
vegas i think they moved to seattle
and just kills it because people believe
in their mission like believe in their
artistic integrity and like it's hard to
argue with that
when you believe in a story when you
believe in a narrative i mean look at
elon my favorite example is elon right
i don't want to bash tesla or anything
but
tesla doesn't make any money people
believe in elon's vision for the future
is there anything wrong with that not
when the government keeps printing
dollars there's nothing wrong with it
right and so
it's a cycle we i can talk about the
economics of that forever but the
reality is
people invest in narratives that they
believe will make the world a better
place
that's how i invest or real estate
because people need it
right that's my feeling of the world i
mean i don't know what's what's your
feeling in the world
how do you feel about crypto how do you
feel about all this stuff oh man i look
at it from too
logical of a standpoint like like very
traditional
so i see bitcoin now as a store of value
originally i saw it as too speculative
and i didn't get
that people couldn't spend it it's not
really a spendable currency so i didn't
truly get it i'm like how do you value
it
it doesn't produce anything it doesn't
pay you off dividends it's not backed by
anything currency is the worst
cryptocurrency is the worst word to ever
happen to crypto
right crypto comes from cryptography the
cryptographic code that all of this
stuff runs on
crypto current the word currency just is
just an incorrect
way of characterizing all this
technology blockchain technology
distributed ledger
technology that's the stuff that's
really cool
currency is just a word that made
crypto into a forex game but like not
and and you're right a lot of this stuff
isn't efficient to spend
um there will be ways in the future that
i think will make it more efficient but
right now you know you're right
right so but yeah now i'm seeing it more
as a store of value that a lot of people
just basically feel
safe with their money in there that it's
not going to be devalued to inflation so
that's why i'm seeing it too so right
now i'm at like i'm getting close to two
percent
of uh my total portfolio in bitcoin and
ethereum
and that is a great start and for me it
started at
around two to three to five percent and
now
it's a little bit no it's not quite 15.
it's maybe
third well excluding excluding this
last event right let's exclude that for
a second right
50 multi-family real estate assets
and that fought three to five grew to
30. um and then the rest in cash
and plus my personal home right how much
in cash do you keep
not a lot okay i don't i'm not gonna
disclose that but i i don't i i mean
enough that if everything went wrong i
mean when i say not a lot i mean that's
relative i guess right
five million dollars peanuts
my perspective is a little bit my
perspective is warped there when i say
not a lot i mean enough for me to live
the rest of my life very comfortably
right so whatever that means very common
i mean that sounds like
i like investing in people and and ideas
and i like particularly d5 protocols
which is a whole other
like rabbit hole of crypto that we don't
need to get into that is using stable
dollars so
the question is how much do i keep in
cash i view my
crypto cash as equally as valuable as
cash that's fair um
so if you counted that we'd be at a
whole different than that okay we're
talking about like
usdc or like 80 interest on usdc
yes is that what you're doing it's just
usbc compound yeah you can earn eight
percentages
no so block fi is centralized okay um
block five is like a bank account
so what do you use to get eight percent
compound it's it's just called compound
it's called compound c5 protocol it's
very complicated
don't recommend it like so don't do you
don't you don't i don't teach you like
i don't do comments i'll bring you over
to my place i'll show you how to use a
ledger
the security of it it's like very
complicated but you can earn eight
percent on compound
so i'm doing block fi that is
is a great company what do they pay six
uh six and a half
yeah no no no usdc i think it's like
eight okay but bitcoin ethereum is about
six so the difference between block fine
compound is block fi
custodies your crypto they actually have
your crypto compound
i still have the right to claim my
crypto from a smart contract that exists
on the blockchain so no one else can
touch it whereas block fi
if they went bankrupt for whatever
reason you're screwed right with crypto
like
i the blockchain determines it is
impossible
for anybody to change the fact that i
have a call on this money
so you're saying i could put like a
million bucks in compound
i mean it's 80 grand a year risk-free
the risk what's the rate the risk is is
a hack
which happens but but why is compound so
valuable
it's one of the first protocols that
does this very securely
what's more likely a bank getting hacked
or my account my compound account
getting hacked
well so you the real question is what's
the risk
what's the difference between
counterparty risk and smart contract
risk and now we get really technical so
we don't i mean i can dive into it if
you want can we can we simplify
in like 30 seconds like one does this
30 seconds i wanted to make a real
estate investment and i rolled down to
bank of america here in las vegas i
wanted to make a big real estate
investment i was putting i was putting
half a million dollars in a property in
florida okay
and you know i'm
gonna wire this money and there's no one
in the branch that has the authorization
to wire this money i need to get it in
by friday it's monday
okay come back tomorrow yeah whatever
first of all i should be able to do that
online that's ridiculous right and i
moved everything to jp morgan
america is terrible jp morgan yeah bank
of america is a horrendous
great situation jp morgan awesome chase
awesome
so monday trying to make this investment
oh we don't have the right authorization
okay come back tomorrow
uh oh they're on vacation so you might
have to wait like till next week are you
kidding me i'm it's my money dude
what are you joking i cancelled
everything and
moved yep and even then like so that's
counterparty risk in a sense right like
what if i missed that investment
opportunity
because someone else had custody of my
funds with crypto you custody your own
funds it's like
having a gold vault and i don't like
making this analogy because crypto is
not similar to gold in a lot of ways and
similar in other ways
but it's like you have a gold vault in
your house and you imagine you could
like imagine you had dollars which are
it's hard like diamonds is a better
example you have a vault of diamonds
that you could actually spend on
something
the bank isn't holding it you have them
in your house and it's safe right like
the idea that with block fi you're
keeping your money with a counterparty
who has certain rights on the you know
has a reserve requirement
but otherwise they do something called
hypothecation
which you know we don't we don't we
don't have to go into sure okay
like how banks work is like banks banks
suck this is why i've been involved in
the crypto space because it's more
efficient
so uh so you want to ask a few questions
jack jack jack always answers
yeah i have a couple questions sure so
um how do the funds settle like after
you sell your nft
obviously i mean you receive everything
in like ethereum what if you receive it
all in ethereum and then there's like a
30
plummet like or do you immediately sell
so that's a great question so you can
program the smart contract to
automatically swap so
this is where like the computer nerd
comes out where like internet money can
do whatever you want it to do so i can
program a smart contract to immediately
convert it to
a stable asset when it hits my wallet
after a sale
in my case on my website we built a
platform where it's all stable coin and
credit card
right so none of it actually you could
you could deposit eth but it swapped it
for you when you deposited it
but you could only bid in stablecoin and
usb you know what i'm going to tell you
so i was curious how these bits
i didn't believe the bids in the
beginning and i thought like
what can anyone just go on and type in
whatever number they want so i logged in
i
made an account and i just wanted to see
if i could place a bid and i was like
then it would be like how realistic is
it or people really putting in money
and sure enough as soon as i went to put
in the bed it's like link your account
usdc like these supported coins
like it's all legit like you have to
have the money to go in there
so if you use it's incredible something
happened in the auction this is a great
point
someone there's a pre-auth on the credit
card for a low number but we don't
charge it until the end
right in good faith we assume someone
put
fat put a fat finger 413 thousand dollar
bit on the first day
we charged the card got declined
canceled the bid immediately
now if that happened towards the end of
the auction would have been really bad
because leaderboard so we actually
disabled like credit cards were enabled
for anyone that first used credit cards
and wasn't irresponsible so we kept it
enabled for those people
um but on the second day of the auction
towards the end if you wanted to create
a new account you had to use the
stablecoin
because we found this error now we know
how to fix it in the future which is we
do
basically you set your max we pre-off
that max
and then you can bid with those funds
right but it's already
authorized and done right whereas
instead of us
hitting hitting stripe you know which we
did when it hit 413 we hit it and
canceled it within 30 minutes you know
but if that happened at the end of the
auction it would have been a disaster
but this is our first time building this
tool so it was a great learning
experience but it worked flawlessly and
it ended up being great
um but yeah no i mean we built this on
the website smart
and then what's the difference between
compound and cold storage
so compound is a d5 protocol cold
storage just means that you store
the private keys the passwords to your
crypto wallets on a hardware device
totally different d5 protocol is like
a pool it's liquid uh liquidity pooling
it's like
there's a lot there without
unfortunately i'm happy to come back on
and talk about but
um cold storage is something that
everyone should consider when you buy
bitcoin or ethereum or have stable coins
you you get a ledger i recommend ledger
there's also treasure but i recommend
ledger
and it's literally a little usb device
that encrypts
the passwords to your wallet on the
blockchain so it's not like you're
storing the money on
the usb drive like people think that
you've actually put the ethereum on the
usb
no it just is an encrypted code that
unlocks
your wallet on the blockchain it's
almost like a
uh the keys to the car you know that
makes sense i always thought
you did like bitcoin that's what i
thought i thought you'd take the code
and you put it on this little heart
thumb drive that's what i thought
well you used to be able to do that you
could take a private key and put it on a
thumb drive but that's super not safe so
ledger is is an encrypted device that
you can't read the data from it it can
only send it well
it can only send data you can't take the
data off of it
which is why it's encrypted the crypt
it's encrypted cryptographically the
password to your wallets but your
wallets all live on the blockchain so
if i'm checking my accounts i can
literally look at my wallet address
but only i have the device that unlocks
that address it's just like an unlock
it's not like you store the bitcoin on
the wow hardware yeah yeah it's a big
misconception
very worth you know worth mentioning one
more thing
where would you say is the best resource
and most unbiased
objective resource that people can use
to get more knowledgeable on crypto
nfts and like that whole like universe
because there's so many people telling
you they're thinking there's a lot i
have
no idea who that is information and i
have i'm probably gonna take a large
portion of this 11.7 million i'm
probably dedicating a million to crypto
education tools
like developing a website that has that
answers should i start a youtube channel
man but i'm gonna probably develop an
education ecosystem that just has like
very like
i'm gonna get all my friends in crypto
that are you know very reputable like
fred erizam who started coinbase like
just to co-sign that all the information
is correct
and basically write a little bit of a
bible a beginner's guide
because people there isn't a good place
to learn coinbase has great resources
and if you want to learn more about nfts
uh openc has the
nft bible which is a great place to
start but
you you kind of it kind of needs to be
think about learning about crypto like
math class
you can't just jump straight to calculus
you have to learn addition and
subtraction
and multiplication and pemdas before you
go
to calculus and derivatives right like
you can't understand
what the derivative of x squared is
until you even understand
like variables and functions right so
think of crypto as like this new
mathematical language that everyone's
gonna at some point have to learn
but they don't have to know everything
they just have to know the basics
like you know how to when you're paying
for something in the store
you have to know addition and
subtraction to know that they're
charging you the right thing on your
group on your bill everyone knows that
right there's gonna be certain basic
crypto knowledge that everyone's gonna
need to know
but beyond that it's just up to you to
know it right like
the knowledge that you spread about real
estate and earning compound interest and
returns
like this is stuff that you're doing a
service for the community because a lot
of kids don't even know they just keep
their money in the bank account right
so you're already taking them to step
two with crypto
there just aren't that many resources
that take you to step three and four and
five
so i'm definitely gonna take a big
portion of this money and build
educational tools for people i think
it's so
important and i'm already like talking
to my team about like who do i want to
hire to build this for me because i
obviously don't have the time but i can
review it
fact check it and i want to build like i
don't know what the name of the website
is yet but like
just crypto crypto.edu or whatever and
like maybe i'll buy that domain it's
probably worth
probably very expensive domain but
crypto.edu and it's just a
beautiful website that says this is what
an nft is
this is what bitcoin is this is what
ethereum is bitcoin is a store of value
ethereum is a
protocol for decentralized applications
and d5 products
like all these words that i'm saying to
you you're like what the hell am i this
is what defy means
right like if you google defy like five
million things come up that like
are all different because it is really
complicated but for our generation and
i'm 30 i don't know
30. you're 30. how old are you jake 22
22.
even more important for you like
learning about this stuff
in 10 years is gonna be like knowing how
to use the internet
it is we've proven that bitcoin went
from
zero to 50 000 in 10 years so
inevitably you have to just bet on
technology
going exponential because it always has
historically
right so eventually you know if you guys
learn sooner than other people
you'll have an advantage and hopefully
you'll make more money perfect
so that's the hope we love it last thing
look into that camera
tell everybody to smash the like button
for the youtube algorithm
everybody smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm right now
and subscribe and subscribe and get your
two free stocks down below in the
description
and get your two free stocks down below
in the description
and get your two free stocks down below
in the description perfect thank you
thank you so much for coming
i really appreciate it this has been so
much fun to free stock thing uh
weeble weeble yeah when you deposit 100
on the platform they'll give you two
stocks worth all the way to 1850
jack usually wears his weeble shirt but
not today weeble
awesome thank you so much man thank you
appreciate it of course
you have to do the introduction it's a
thing with their guests you have to say
hi my name is justin
if you want to serve justin blau uh
welcome to the 40
let's say 40 42nd 42nd
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
so far the podcast has made we'll give
you the amount
yeah and uh then jack will say wow
that's a really good
introduction welcome back to the 43rd
every episode
of the iced coffee hour and then that's
the guy yeah
solo oh welcome back to the 43rd
ever iced coffee hour my name is blau
and this ep
wait and welcome back to the 43rd ever
episode of the iced coffee hour my name
is blau aka or justin aka blah
and uh so far the podcast is made that
much hold on
you got this i'm so sorry yeah
say it one more time welcome back to the
43rd ever
episode of the iced coffee hour my name
is justin aka blau
and so far the podcast has made welcome
back to the 43rd ever episode